andy staples covers college football for
the athletic host of the andy staples
show podcast he joins us on the program
why was this game cancelled andy ohio
state in michigan
well we knew michigan had some covet
issues and and we knew that last week
and
as soon as michigan paused last week you
had a feeling
this was going to happen because when
these things happen they tend to take
out
a couple of games and that was the issue
what shocks me is the big ten was not
creating some sort of contingency plan
to figure out what was going to happen
with the big ten title game because as
the rules currently stand
ohio state will not be eligible now
what's funny about this or no
none of it's funny what's crazy about
this is if ohio state just
lost this saturday they would be
eligible to play in the big ten title
game
because then they would have played six
games which is the minimum requirement
and they would have the head-to-head win
against indiana so they would just go in
but no the big ten in its infinite
wisdom decided there had to be a fixed
number of games is the minimum
to make the title game none of the other
leagues did that because the other
leagues are a lot smarter
than the big ten on every single front
this whole year are they talking about
changing that rule i mean this is
a fluid situation as i mentioned about
15 minutes ago
and it feels like everything's on the
table barry alvarez was a big proponent
in
hey it doesn't matter how many games you
know you need to qualify for the big ten
title but that was when wisconsin was
still in the race
now it's ohio state do you think they're
going to make accommodations for them to
play in the big ten title game
no matter even if they don't play
another game
i think they should and my co-host ari
wasserman on the podcast had a great
point
ohio state no and northwestern have
already clinched their spots in the
title game
just have them play on saturday shuffle
the schedule round have them play
saturday
and then have everybody play some other
games next week because
at this point we already know ohio state
is the best team in the big ten east
so what are we doing here why not just
have them play in the title game
there is no reason that they had that
six game
arbitrary number they didn't need to do
that
and you've seen other leagues do some
things to help their teams i mean the
acc a few weeks ago
shuffled their schedule so that notre
dame and clemson would have
a bye week before the the championship
game why not
do something to help one of your teams
that has bothered me
the entire time about the big ten
they've done nothing
to help any of these teams like when
nebraska loses a game and they try to
schedule chattanooga the big ten's like
no no no you can't do that
and nebraska said when that got canceled
hey you know our teams might need to get
some other games
for playoff consideration or just to
have enough games to play
this might be a little short-sighted and
the big ten office response was like
bart noise basically is ohio state
actively looking for an opponent for
this weekend
well they're not going to bring in a
non-conference opponent because they're
not allowed to
and ideally i mean if we really wanted
to just have the best matchup if
you know we should have learned
something from coastal carolina byu
because last week coastal carolina
loses his game against liberty because
liberty had coveted issues and they go
hey byu you set any team anytime
anywhere
so how about conway south carolina on
some teal turf
on two days notice and guess what byu
got that big semi rolling from provo and
it crossed the country
and they played what might have been the
most fun game of the season so
here's what i suggest greg sankey from
the sec
kevin warren from the big ten get on the
phone get on a zoom call
and get texas a m which had its game
against ole miss canceled this weekend
get them to columbus because the sec
would love
for texas a m to have a way to prove
that it's better than ohio state because
they're behind ohio state
in the playoff standings right now yeah
but ohio state doesn't have to play
another game and they're in the final
four right now the only way they get
knocked out would be if florida beats
alabama
clemson clemson beats notre dame
you know it feels like ohio state's
going to be in the final four without
i mean they they kept him in there andy
without even playing the michigan game
so i don't know if it matters if they
beat northwestern then all of a sudden
we go oh my god and if i'm ohio state
i'm not giving a m a chance to leapfrog
us
oh of course not but that's what i would
like to see as a viewer
no ohio state is in the playoff at this
point
no matter what and and that is more the
fault of the conferences
for deciding to keep the playoff as is
this year
you know there's no data
cross-conference other than
three sunbelt teams beating three big 12
teams there
we don't know which conference is better
so i
we have this conversation about the
pac-12 well the patent they say the
pac-12 is the weakest power five league
how do you know that they haven't played
anybody outside the fact 12 this year
so my suggestion was just for this year
you need to expand the playoffs so that
all the power 5 champs get in
the highest ranked group of five champ
gets in two at-larges which is what
they're going to expand it to later
anyway
but why not do that because there it
really isn't fair to the big 12 or to
the pac-12 or to the highest ranked
group of five champ with that cincinnati
that they're they're not gonna have a
chance it is i test i test i test
and look if you ask me or if you asked a
vegas line maker
who's the fourth best team ohio state is
a very reasonable answer
and i want to see ohio state in the
playoff i just would rather
it be done differently this year because
we have no out of conference data to
compare
he's andy staples he covers college
football for the athletic and
hosts the andy staples show podcast jim
harbaugh
not being able to play this game um
does it mean anything for his like what
is his future there
i i don't know and you've heard all
these rumors about an extension
my feeling is if you extend jim harbaugh
down his situation is
is unique in college football because
he's got one year left on his contract
he typically does not play the same game
that other coaches do where their agents
come in after a good year and say
well you gotta extend my guy he needs to
have five years on his deal
you know jim harbaugh goes double digit
wins three of his first four years
most places he's getting five years
tacked on at the end of his deal
that didn't happen so now he's going
into next year as the last year on his
contract i
i'm guessing you probably don't want
that to happen so you either have to
decide do you want to keep him
or do you move on and my feeling would
be move on
because your goal at michigan is to win
big 10 titles
your goal is to beat ohio state he
hasn't been
able to do any of those things and in
fact it seems like it's just getting
worse
so if you tried it got a little better
for a while but you never got ultimately
what you wanted
go try to find somebody who can get what
you want
do you think this was a good thing for
michigan football they're not playing
this weekend
i don't think it matters one way or the
other i i mean and it's sort of like the
same thing with ohio state
would ohio state beating this michigan
team prove anything
to anyone and and we know what would
happen to michigan in this game i mean
so i i don't think it really changes
anything i i don't think it changes
anything for harbaugh
i just it it's crazy to me dan because i
was sitting there looking at my phone
yesterday after the cancellation
and we've seen all kinds of weird news
this year there's just
you know stuff we never thought would
happen and i'm looking at it and it was
the first time in a while that the
stories just hit me like
oh my god they canceled michigan ohio
state
like it just sinks in that this is just
a weird
weird year you had a
a really detailed column about texas
football and
you know there was the reporter rumor
that urban meyer
might be kicking the tires there and
that his wife was looking for homes in
austin here
um like nobody is a zillow you have to
fly in and do it in person
um you know i've watched most of texas
games this year and and they could have
gone the other way and we'd be looking
at
you know herman and saying he might be
coach of the year in the big 12 and they
would be playing for the big 12
championship
if i'm a texas fan am i staying with
coach herman here
are we looking elsewhere well the fans
are ready to move on
they are ready to go but but my thing is
if you can't get an urban meyer
and let's think about how many real slam
dunk hires have worked out
in college football in the last 20 years
urban meyer did it twice
at florida and at ohio state i would
argue that nick saban
was a was a successful slam dunk hire at
alabama
and brian kelly was at notre dame and
we'll see about jimbo fisher at texas a
m he has a couple more years like this
we'll add him to that list but it's a
very short list
so you can't get anybody like that if
you compare the other names that we'd be
talking about whether it's mario
kristabal or matt campbell james
franklin
are they going to do any better than
herman does
i i don't really know i mean you know he
was pretty close this year
but it's still not what you want because
you know they lose to tcu
they he's lost to tcu three times that
shouldn't happen at texas they lose to
iowa state
with with a trip to the big 12 title
game online that shouldn't happen at
texas you should
have better players and in most of those
games you should have a significant
talent advantage
and then yeah every once in a while
somebody's going to get you but
really it should be you and oklahoma
duking it out at the top
and that's tom herman's problem it's
it's not that he hasn't been competitive
against oklahoma because he's been very
competitive against oklahoma
it's winning against those other teams
and the question is yeah but if you're
saying
30 million bucks yeah but we you know
you're you want to move or they may want
to move on
who you're getting the same can be said
about michigan that
that their fan base probably wants to
move on who are you getting to replace
you know but the thing is you can you
can get somebody doing better than what
jim harbaugh is doing now
you can get something better than what
jim harbaugh has given you the last
couple years
i don't know that texas is going to
given the current pool
get better than what they've gotten from
tom herman because he actually might be
on a decent trajectory
jim harbaugh doesn't feel like he's on a
good trajectory right now
who's winning the heisman
that sec championship game is going to
be a
a very highly watched affair among
heisman voters because you got you got
matt jones and kyle trask and
and obviously both of them have insane
talent around them i think that's
you know people say well trevor lawrence
is is the best player well yes if 32 nfl
gm's voted for the heisman
trevor lawrence would win in a landslide
but that's not how these things usually
work
and so you have to say well is matt
joe's doing this because he's great or
because of devante smith is kyle trask
doing this because he's great or because
of kyle pitts
i think that game will probably decide
it
uh which quarterback plays better if one
quarterback just has a disaster of a
game
it's probably going to the other guy or
if they just have a duel for the ages i
think
the the one who comes out on top
probably winds up winning it by the way
how's the pac-12 doing
they they are still playing they played
some sunday football i watched i watched
usc washington state on sunday it was
great
i thought it was a rear i i swear to god
i i flip through and i go
oh you know what let me watch a little
bit of this game from satin wait
oh no this is actually oh okay like it
was tap me on the shoulder and say we're
playing football
on sunday of course you are well it's
interesting because the pac-12
may have bungled this all worse than the
big ten because
really until the big ten said they're
playing again the pac-12
almost it's almost if they hadn't even
thought of the possibility of trying to
play this season
and so it doesn't look good
they're hardly getting any games in but
at least they've been flexible that's
that's the one thing they have tried to
be very flexible
uh they created a cal washington game on
two days notice and
and played that on a sunday and and if
you're the big 10 you should look at
that and say
well we could probably figure out a
solution to this ohio state issue
and get them another game if we just be
a little creative like they've been but
the big ten is is not that aircraft
carrier does not turn around very well
andy great to talk to you
and we'll be reading we'll be watching
thank you
thanks dan that's andy staples covers
college football for the athletic and
host of the andy staples
show podcast